j'ai la couv de public de demain non il
ya un couple qui a repris apparemment
d'après public
je suis devenu où j'ai vu as a way jeu
c'est incroyable je sais non non alors
attendez arrêter de dire qu'on sait on
sait on sait pas les téléspectateurs je
vais leur dire eh ouais c'est une matin
c'est vous les tissus un ami à vous
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup et
salami c'est un humoriste
oui quand même moi qui n'aime pas oui
mais que moi j'aime beaucoup j'aime bien
yann moix
j'aime mes mais j'aime beaucoup les
trouve très drôle et il a beaucoup de
talent je pensais pas un mois a lancé à
niveau je pensais être balayés du toko
permis banon alors j'ai pensé du coup à
karine et joey karine le marchand
c'est pour ça il maurice ça m'a fait
acheter il est pas humoriste à part
quand tu vois des pizzas non mais c'est
vrai mais john je sais pas mais en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire regardez
j'ai eu la larme à l'oeil
d'ailleurs il paraîtrait que quévenois
aurait récupéré iris oui donc à la deux
clament en fait en ce moment arrêtée boy
sorti sortir
[Applaudissements]
allez vous dire l'amour a été plus fort
que la danse apparemment en tout cas si
c'est vrai je suis très heureux pour eux
parce que je les aime beaucoup voilà
j'aime beaucoup iris et j'aime beaucoup
encore plus kiev qui est un ami alors
voilà et apparat bon voilà c'est cesser
et je viens d'un traité de potiche à
nantua cas où vous l'avez traité fort
selon l'angleterre avec j'ai un peu
marketing de l'alliance entre entre le
ch de danseurs comment s'appelait alors
jusque là on a failli y aller car vous
allez nous dire si vous pensez que c'est
un coup c'est la rumeur people du moment
iris ménard miss france miss univers et
récemment finaliste de l'émission danse
avec les stars seraient de retour avec
son ex-petite amie d'humoristes kiev à
dams selon le magazine public qui publie
en une de son magazine des photos des
deux tourtereaux à la gare de lyon le
couple se serait reformé il y a peu
après plusieurs mois de relations la
miss avait décidé de rompre cet été à
cause de l'emploi du temps surchargé de
kev adams mais cette fois-ci l'humoriste
semble avoir compris la leçon en
réservant du temps et ris et en
l'accompagnant lors d'une séance de
dédicace à lyon pour son autobiographie
intitulée toujours y croire
un titre qui prend tout son sens avec
cette histoire
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
info voile alors l'on sait pas si elle
est vraie en tout cas si c'est vrai moi
je suis très heureux pour les deux parce
que j'ai voilà vous savez que c'est un
j'ai une tendresse très grandes
promesses pour kiev adams et si le refus
très content que vous vous parliez
gilles et moi on n'arrêtait pas surtout
j'ai d'ailleurs de dénoncer côté un peu
marketing un peu fake de certaines
histoires d'amour au cnda ce notamment
celles d'iris avec anthony colette son
soudan alors est-ce que c'était officiel
cette histoire ah non je n'avais pas
fait tout ce qu'ils ont dit non voilà
c'est ça brasse car on dit qu'ils ont
jamais été ensemble pendant des mois ce
que ça veut dire non mais dans les
journaux aussi people souvent vous êtes
comme ça vous êtes avec une meuf elle
est à elle est à côté de vous ils disent
vous êtes avec l ouvrage demain je me
balade avec gide et dit gilles verdez
avec cyril hanouna ça m'arrangerait pas
mais c'est vrai qu'on pourrait on pourra
passer c'est vrai dans nos maisons
voilà on pourra fermer mais oui non mais
jean michel arion c'est honteux parce
qu'il joue avec ça pour faire venir les
gens et même pendant les prime alors
avait l'air étrangement proche alors
regardez juste voilà il avait la veille
il y avait une complicité vous allez
nous dire sur van der garde et les
complicités complicité fait
je pense que je n'irai jamais set avant
que je sais pas quoi regarder cette
émission car j'étais plus jeune j'avais
15 ans je n'en sais pas encore et
maintenant je vois que
[Musique]
tu te retrouveras finale avec thierry
sans plus
c'est exceptionnel official rien
d'officiel retient encore missions
d'entretien la main comme lui tient la
main il ya eu une détonation quand même
l'année c'est pas un problème j'ai vu
deux français et six heures par jour
avec quelqu'un forcément que ça crée des
liens
mais non mais non mr à léonie c'est que
tout cas je vous dis voilà c'était
c'était l'info vraiment moi qui a qui
m'a pris la tête
j'étais comme ça j'ai pas pris un coup
de fil la voix les patrons de canal maps
et je ne veux pas vous parler
j'ai voyagé theora sera totale ici
mouais